RONY ROZEN: If your app
displays large amounts of data,
chances are you're using--
or at least should be using--
a UITableView or a
UICollectionView.
The goal of these
UI components is
to make your life
easier when dealing
with large amounts of data.
But if you don't
use them properly,
you can end up with a far
from perfect user experience.
Let me share a couple of
UITableView optimization tips
that are also relevant
for UICollectionView.
Your users will
thank you for this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you don't optimize
your UITableView use,
there will be a lag when
the user is scrolling.
That's, obviously,
not the smooth user
experience you want to provide.
So what can you do?
Let's start with the simplest,
yet most significant tip.
We use Identifier.
You see, the way you
UITableView works
is that new cells
are rendered right
before they enter the screen
as the user is scrolling.
At the same time,
other cells that
have recently left the screen
are waiting to be reused.
So using these cells that
were already rendered
will be significantly more
efficient than creating
new cells from scratch.
The way to do this is to
provide each type of cell
with a reuse identifier
when it's initially created,
and ask for cells with
the same identifier
whenever a new cell
needs to be rendered.
This is done using UITableView's
dequeueReusableCell method.
You provide the relevant
use identifier string,
and the method returns a cell
with the same user identifier.
If there is an already rendered
cell that can be reused,
this is what the
method will return.
If you have a custom
class for this cell,
you should use the
register cellClass
forCellReuseIdentifier
method, so
that the dequeueReuseableCell
method will not fetch or create
an instance of the
matching class.
Note that if you have
multiple cell types,
say, a list of classes
and a list of students
for each class, you should make
sure to use different reuse
identifiers for
each type of cell.
This will ensure
that when calling
the dequeueReuseableCell
method, the return cell
will have the right
structure, and will save you
the setup time.
So now that we have our new
UITableView cell object,
or a custom subclass,
we need to make
sure it displays the
relevant content.
This is done in the TableView
cellForRow indexPath method.
Our goal is to make this
method implementation as short
and to the point as possible.
This is not the place
for complex computations,
image manipulations, or any
other time-consuming actions.
All of the heavy lifting
needs to be done elsewhere
and be prepared by the time
this method is reached.
Otherwise, you
guessed it, you can
forget about smooth scrolling.
Needless to say that it is
not the place for dealing
with off-screen displays.
Anything that isn't going
to be presented in the cell,
or can be calculated
elsewhere, and not
in the cellForRow indexPath
method doesn't belong here.
In addition to keeping
this method implementation
short, quick, and
to the point, you
need to make sure that
you're loading images
from the web on a
background thread.
You don't want your display to
lag, or even worse, get stuck,
while you're
waiting for an image
to be loaded and displayed.
It'll be a significantly
better user experience
to show the cell immediately and
have the content from the web
join a short while
after, when it's ready.
Make sure to also
cache everything
you can so that the
next time the user
scrolls to a row that was
already displayed in the past,
there will be no need to wait.
The image will
appear immediately,
since it was already
loaded and cached.
There are multiple open
source libraries out there
that can save you the
effort of implementing
these improvements yourself.
A simple Google Search
can find several of them,
and you can pick your
personal favorite.
One example is Kingfisher,
a lightweight, swift library
for downloading and caching
images from the web.
The simplest use case
will look like this.
This will allow you to load
the image of your choosing,
cache it, and if you attempt
to load the same image later,
it will be retrieved from cache
and not reloaded from the web.
Another tip that
can significantly
improve the scrolling
experience is
to make sure that the cell's
background is completely
opaque, and, if possible, has
a single consistent background
color, and not a
gradient, for example.
So unless you need the cell's
background to be transparent,
and are willing to possibly
pay for it in performance,
make sure to have an opaque
background color for each cell,
especially if it's the same
color as the view's background.
I used UITableView
for these tips,
but they are also
relevant UICollectionView.
Give them a try and see for
yourself how much smoother
you're scrolling gets.
I can assure you your users
will notice and appreciate it
as well.
Until next time, I'm Rony
Rozen for "Route 85."
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]